("Jingle Bells" instrumental playing)
- Dear Santa, I would like
a few things for Christmas.
A couple of them are,
world peace, long hair and
bring the Queen of England
back to life.
And if you can't do that,
I'll take a couple new
books, sparkling water, coal,
piece of chocolate, and piece of gum
for my science experiment.
Thank you Santa. Goodbye.
(audience applauding)
- I like the way
you think, Juliet.
So all week we feature
letters to Santa from kids
like Juliet as part of a team effort
with our season long
partner, Pilot Frixion Pen,
the go-to erasable pen of
the "Kelly Clarkson Show".
And the goal is to take
a little pressure off
Old Saint Nick this year.
Juliet, we want to celebrate
kindhearted, adorable kids
creating unique and impressive
Christmas lists like you.
So we're gonna give
you a thousand dollars.
(audience applauding)
I'm not sure if it can
bring the queen back to life
or totally trigger world
peace but, well maybe,
you never know, but you
should be set on books, gum
and chocolate. Merry Christmas.
(audience applauding)
And to everyone watching,
remember you can pick up
Pilot Frixion Erasable Pens
wherever office supplies are sold.